all right Deanna
Deanna where are you from originally
where'd you go at Chino California Gino
and tell me about your family
uh one of six kids
um
born and raised in Southern California
my entire life
this is kind of number five
what was your relationship like with
your parents
Mom and Dad divorced when I was young
there was a stepfather
um didn't really have a relationship
with my mother there was some issues
but I didn't think I was gonna cry
somebody's just early on when I was two
and a half I was putting a tub of hot
water
um just a little bit of backstory my mom
was very young she had some issues of
her own so I kind of
gave her some slack she was very young
she was pregnant at 15. and by the time
I was born she was 22 I was her fifth
child
I had a younger sister a year and a half
and then she was pregnant with her
last child
um so it's two and a half and um
I must have soiled myself or something I
don't know but my she had my older
sister who was four at the time right on
top of hot water for a bath
and I didn't want to get in but
my mom came in and put me in the water
and and just went back to the kitchen to
do whatever she was doing
um I was screaming of course I don't
remember that day I was screaming
and my older sister reports that um she
tried to pull me out but couldn't
because I was too heavy so my mom just
kept yelling back just take her out so I
don't know how long I was in the tub
quite a while because I had blisters on
my feet
um by the time I was pulled out of the
water so the water was very hot enough
to blister it wasn't just hot bath water
it was
yeah because snowman bath water doesn't
blister but yeah you can deduce what you
want
um the official story is my sister ran
the water I got in the water my sister
couldn't get me out of the water
um but of course you know as I grew up
and I had my own kids I realized a
two-year-old cannot get herself into the
water because if they did they'd go
ahead first and I wasn't burned from the
head I was burned from the feet up so
did you switch you which you can from
that story what was the aftermath of
that
um I was my mom took me to the hospital
and immediately they suspected child
abuse so they did an investigation
nothing ever came of it
um this official story was Sister around
the water mom was busy with the kitchen
um so there's really nothing that came
of it after that but
um there was an issue where the doctor
had prescribed the wrong antibiotic
um as just a little background um am I
am actually a nurse so um when you have
an infection because an infection came
in
um
you have to prescribe an antibiotic he's
a gram negative or gram-positive they
prescribe the wrong one so I went septic
it's about five six days in hospital
they'd called my dad my mom and dad were
divorced at this point they called my
dad I'm not sure why and told them if
you don't get her out of here by morning
she'll be dead so because what happened
was the blood shunts from your
extremities to the organs to protect
them so my toes were black my fingertips
were black my ears were black my nose
was black if things were starting to
shunt so they sent me over to Children's
Hospital Los Angeles
and that's when the initial plan was to
cut the legs up to here
but there was a doctor there that said
no we have this new procedure so they
actually only took took the ankle odd
the foot off I still had the ankle
so you mentioned so I had the full leg
with the ankle
um I later had a revision so now of
course I'm up to to hear bilaterally
both legs
both legs up to here because I had a
revision in my early 20s that's another
chapter in the story
um why that had to happen
but so they they took the feet off at
the ankles
so and did your mom or anyone take
responsibility for what happened my
mother never took responsibility
no
she
she raised me to basically like this I I
wasn't she wouldn't hold me she wouldn't
I mean initially she took care of the
bandages and and took care of the wounds
and stuff initially she did that but my
memories of my mom were just I remember
just growing up talking to my older
sister like Mom hates me she she hates
me and she blames me for the accident
because I was told
I try not to his name so my sister ran
the water and I got in it but then why
is my mom treating me like this
um but I mean when I got home from
school it was
um go to your room and take your legs
off and I wasn't seen till dinner time
and that's happened for years and years
and years I pretty much lived majority
of my younger childhood in my bedroom
my mom didn't want to see me didn't want
to hear me I felt like it was at this
point now I just feel like I was
probably a constant reminder
um it's kind of what it felt like but
yeah I grew up to my sister she hates me
she doesn't love me so she loves you she
just doesn't know
I don't know what she would what the
excuse I can't even remember anymore
it's been so long did you treat your
sister differently oh yeah oh yeah
everybody else was running around
playing outside with the with with their
friends
um I would be looking out the window all
my siblings were out playing in the
streets I was in my room I wasn't
allowed to go out I was I had to take
the legs off and go to my room
and when I was allowed out and again I
blame my mom just the ignorance
um she was told
that I needed to walk on the legs to
toughen them up
but not knowing what I know now as an
adult and as a nurse
she understood it that I had to walk on
the stumps
so we're talking an ankle with bones and
Scar Tissue very thin skin there's no
padding I was working on concrete carpet
marble tile I'd have to walk on the
stumps
um and that I always had constant skin
breakdowns
and I I think she just
misunderstood the doctors I think what
they meant was she needs to walk on her
leg you know in the Prosthetics but she
understood it differently take the legs
off and then walk on the stubs my
stepfather would do this but later my
mom would repeat this this procedure but
in order to teach me how to swim you
know if you still the diving boards
they're very gritty and hard I would
have to stand all my stumps not knowing
how to swim looking at the deep water
going I'm either going to drown or I'm
going to die standing up here it just
was so painful and there's many many
times we just that's how they try to
teach me how to swim standing on the
diving boards with the stumps and it was
so painful
how are your high school years
um I was bullied all the way from grade
school to ninth grade I was bullied
um
and I would come home crying and my mom
would like I don't want to hear it go to
your room
so
yeah I mean just
yeah I was
relentless
um it did I had no friends pretty much
until I went to high school then because
once you're in high school there's a lot
more smaller schools funneled into a big
school and a lot of kids didn't know and
I was able to make friends then but
elementary junior high no not at all it
was it was very rough
and how has this impacted your adult
life
well I just there's there was a lot
going on
um and there's there's a lot of incest
too I think I haven't talked about that
but there was quite a bit of that going
on as well in the home
um
but I just knew as far as the legs go
that
um by the time I was probably about 16
years old I just figured I just realized
that
I can't be a victim I can only you know
I can't
fix what happened and I can't change
what happened
but I have control of my future
so I just was counting the days to the
day I turned 18 and I could move out and
just put everything behind me
whatever happened if it was it was
malicious or not at this point it
doesn't matter it happened
so just let it go and I only have
control over my future
um
and that's pretty much how I've been
living my life and just looking forward
and not looking back
and just that this is my challenge I
mean we each have our crosses to bear
and our burdens and this one is mine for
some reason it is
um and that's going to be hers meaning
my mother that's her she's going to have
to to live with that and I
I just have to keep moving forward in
the incest that you mentioned that that
was oh my yeah there was
um
um my mother's second husband my
stepfather
um he had a son
who anytime my mom would would leave he
was babysitting and he would strip me
and my sister down
naked every time she left and just
one story he would take my sister's
stuffed animals and pretend to have oral
sex
with the animals
um
yeah and this this went on for years
until they divorced and he moved out
yeah there was a lot of that going on
and yeah I suspect it happened earlier
as well
um
I was used to my mom told me I used to
be my stepfather's favorite every time I
came home I had this long blonde curly
hair I was the first one he would seek
out
and when the accident happened he wanted
nothing to do with me once the accident
happened didn't want nothing to do with
me
um in fact yeah if we didn't sleep at
night we'll go to bed like we were
supposed to talk too much we would have
I both my sister and I would have to
stand behind the recliner
with our noses against the wall for
hours and of course I'm standing on
stumps for hours
and anyway so I suspect that because
what happened was I found out later that
my older sister became his favorite and
I found out later that um he was
blessing her for years so I suspect this
has been going on for a long time
so
and then and then yeah and then
yeah my mom
after they got divorced my mom was
forced to go to work and
um
so things changed a little bit in the
beginning I still had to go to my room
and take the legs off and all that stuff
because my sisters would snatami my
family would snitch on me
um so that still went on for a while but
then once they started to get a little
busy with their boyfriends and stuff I
was able to like have more of a normal
teenage childhood where I could go
outside to play with the friends because
Mom was at work
um but then there was some boyfriends
that would come in my room at night
who would
do what they do and I just remember when
I was getting ready for church my
grandmother my dad's mom she's more like
my motherly figure
so I really relied on her for that
nurturing because I didn't I didn't have
it at home
um and I actually are getting ready for
church and I was waiting for my grandma
and one of the boyfriends
put me on his lap and stuck his tongue
down my throat and he had a mustache and
I could just smell the sex on his face
and it just it the whole day there was
just I could smell my mother's vagina on
my mouth in my face
and
yeah this
how was your adult life
pretty good like I said once I turned 18
um I had control of my my life at that
point I didn't have you know I just had
control so it was good I'm in right out
of high school I met a boy we got
engaged
um we were going to be married and then
he died in a car crash too much for the
wedding
and a year later I actually know a
couple months later actually met my
husband and we were married a year later
and it was a great Christian Life
um pretty normal
um early on when we were first married I
think it was about 22-23 had gone I had
a lot of bone infections because of
constantly walking on the stumps and
always having skin tears of course I
picked at him a lot too but
um so that didn't help so they have a
revision so they took them up to about
four inches below the knee
um but yeah it just lived a pretty
normal life I wanted to be a nurse my
entire life
um but I was constantly told you're too
stupid you can't work
um you'll never be a nurse you can't do
12-hour shifts
and and initially when I when I met the
first boyfriend the first fiance I was
going to do I was doing my prerequisites
in college
and when he died I stopped going to
college I got went through a really bad
depression
and then I kind of let all those voices
get ahead of me in my head that you know
I can't do it
um
and by the time I was 26 I just like I
had this strong passion to be a nurse
from my youngest youngest memory I just
said [__] it I'm gonna do it I told my
husband I said I don't care if I can't
work a day in my life I'm not happy I
need my passion is to be a nurse I'm
going to go to school I'm going to be
nerd if I can't work a day then I can't
work a day but at least I know I did it
and at least I know I tried instead of
saying I can't
so went to nursing school and I worked
two years floor nursing in a pediatric
ICU for two years it was tough doing 12
hour shifts I couldn't do the typical
mostly nurses work worth three days on
and I have four or five days off I'd
have to work a day take one to two off
because of the swelling and the
blistering and stuff because 12 hours is
a long time on your legs on your feet
when you have Prosthetics so I did that
for almost two years
and then I went into case management so
then I just now I just
you know my kids joke joke with me
they're like yeah you just sit at a desk
all day I'm like yeah well I'm using my
brain smart enough to at least use my
brain and not my body so you're raising
kids remember I have three kids
um that's another story too yeah my my
husband couldn't have kids so we had
infertility tried for 10 years couldn't
have kids
um finally I've just and we always
wanted to adopt anyway but he just kept
saying I want to keep trying I want to
keep trying finally was about 10 years
into the marriage finally told him I
said if we don't adopt I said we're
going to divorce because I have to have
kids and I didn't realize how bad why I
had to have kids so bad until probably
about five years ago and I realized that
and we have three adopted boys we we
adopted them through the county
um but I was able to give them the love
and the attention and the the just
everything that I should have had as a
kid and to me that just made everything
better because not having kids I just
feel like all that abuse was for nothing
so yeah I just my kids are amazing I
just I love them to death and they've
they've been very healing for me
as far as having to you know reflect on
the past this I feel like I've just
made everything just better because I've
changed their lives
but he learned most from all of this
you've been through
you can't hold on to stuff you can't
hold on it just if you hold on to that
that negativity and that victimhood and
that just blackness in your heart you
have to let it go you have to forgive
and just let it go and
otherwise you can't move forward you'll
be paralyzed and stuck and that just to
me I wasn't going to waste my life on
that
so like I said earlier that's she's
gonna have to deal with that I just need
to make sure my life
is
successful and fruitful and happy
it's wonderful
all right Deanna thank you so much I'm
so glad you're doing well now thank you
thank you very much